DJ beat me yep
so guys I had this porch on my apartment
when I like to sit outside and write my
rhymes it's not a bad place to work but
there is this B with an S somewhere
nearby that always flies up in my face
while I'm writing yo I tell him be
aggressive be he flies at me
aggressive lead he seems to like to mess
with me with fear I see be aggressive be
check it out now yes sir II don't think
less of me but I'm afraid of the
aggressive B especially when he attacks
and I'm just minding my own beeswax I
tried to freeze him breathe deeply try
to wait out the beat till it leaves me
but he won't let me be so I get to let
me BB heebie-jeebies
got my defenses up my teeth clenched my
whole body tenses up should I sing
Roxane or something cuz that little jerk
is all about sting
does he buzz Suri does he's furious I'm
serious not a joke Frida funny bone
he's the Attila the Hun of the honeycomb
there is a pair of wings on the fellow
and a ring of black Ted a ring of jell-o
and he gets me round tight like a string
on a cello he makes me want to freakin
della Trello because he is the one pot
recipe Oh Pete wise at me Tom presently
Joe's my guess you'll be
find the aggressive beat wise right from
his having those dives at me no jive he
isn't terrified of me it's kind of a
surprise to me cuz he's like 1,000 the
size of me t me have a pollen teeny
chill yourself if you sing me you'll
kill yourself that ain't worth it kiddo
you don't want to make your Queen a
yellow and black widow that's not what I
want for you see the truth is beyond
fond to you I feel a bit of a bond with
you hey I even wrote this song for you
but even if I made the B appear sweeter
I'm not trying to be as cheerleader his
hostility is excessive the bees are
aggressive the bees aggressive to me
he's progressive that please